competition has always been the
cornerstone of success
that's why today we're talking about an
up-and-coming bim platform
that's making waves across the entire
world today we're comparing archicad
against bricscad
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me
on this channel we talk about
architecture and technology so if that's
something that interests you make sure
you smash that subscribe button down
below
today we're talking about brix cad and
archicad and we're going to be comparing
them in detail
if you haven't heard about bricscad
before believe it or not they've been
around for almost two decades
and are making waves around the world
because of this whole
revit crisis and major firms stepping up
stating their
displeasement with revit and autodesk
bricscad
has really stepped up here and taken
over some of these major firms
personally i'm an archicad user so
that's why i wanted to make
this review and this video today i want
to use everything i've learned with
archicad over the last five years and
compare it
to this up and coming brix cad platform
like always with these reviews
let's start with price archicad is
a bit of a tricky one to give you a flat
price on because you have to go
and contact a rep to get a basic price
from them
from me and my personal experience it's
been a couple years since we purchased
arcade for the office
but it was approximately 5 500
australian dollars
this is a one-time upfront payment that
allows you to buy
archicad whatever version is out of the
time and it's yours forever
now 5 500 australian dollars is a pretty
good deal
when you compare it to revit which is 5
500
australian every single year but then
when you compare it to brix cad
they're only asking for eighteen hundred
and twenty australian dollars
for a forever license yes this is the
same situation
buy the latest and greatest version and
if you wish to update
it's approximately seven hundred dollars
per year
for both platforms so straight away
in the get-go archicad is going to cost
you two times as much
almost three times as much to set up and
buy versus brix cad bricscad does have a
variety of different licensing options
or different methods that you can sign
up to
so if you are interested in learning
more about their pricing modules you can
check out their website but today we're
just going to be comparing
those two factors there now the next
feature we're going to be talking about
is login capabilities as an archicad
user i've used the archive dongle for a
very long time now
and i absolutely hate the thing every
time i switch between my home computer
my work computer my work laptop that i
travel
to and from perth is a bit of a problem
because i have a genuine tendency to
forget that dongle
every time i need to go on a work trip
it is in my calendar
as a notification to remember to take it
home
so it's a serious serious pain to have
to remember that usb all the time
with bricscad they give you two
different options a network key that
allows you to connect it to as many
computers as you like
as long as you're connected to the
network or a single
license key option which allows you to
connect it up to
two different computers at any given
time if you need a third you simply just
uninstall or remove the key
from one computer to be able to activate
it on another
i really wish archicad had something
that was similar to this
archicad does have a cloud-based system
login system
but again you have to be connected to a
host server or you have to log into the
dongle first
to activate that computer so it is a bit
of a mess around still
at the moment we're in the process of
transitioning to this system so it might
be a little bit better
but my current feelings are that brix
cad has
the better and more powerful login
system so what about the minimum
specifications you need
to run both of these programs now brxcad
gives you some
very questionable information on their
website let me
let me read it to you you need a minimum
of 1 gigabyte ram
one gigabyte of free space and one
gigabyte
processor when you compare that to
archicad
they recommend an i7 processor
16 gigabytes of ram and anywhere from 3
to 3.6 gigahertz
of processing power which means you have
to have a very very powerful computer
to be able to run archicad at its
optimal performance level
the reason i say bricscads
specifications are a little bit
questionable
is because when you start pumping in a
lot of data
and you start modeling masses and masses
and masses
your computer is going to need a lot
more power so yes
you can definitely run brix cad on the
bare minimums of one one one
but personally i'd still recommend
having a good powerful computer to be
able to back up
if you're planning on building something
like a 10-story apartment building
or even a 50-story skyscraper bricscad
has a lot of plugins including
enscape which enscape requires a lot
more
as a minimum processing power than brix
cad does
so if you're looking at the minimum
specs of just bricscad
it's probably a good idea to then look
at all the plugins that you're
looking to use and look at their
performance requirements
for example enscape uses a lot more than
bricscad
enscape requires a minimum of i5 8
gigabytes of ram
and a 2 gigabyte dedicated video card
because it doesn't run on mac
it requires that video card for a
windows operating system
so straight away if you're planning on
using enscape as a pair to brix cad
you're automatically going to need those
higher specs okay so let's get into the
softwares
archicad has a very clean modern ui
that gets updated and refreshed every
single year a new version comes out
in my personal opinion archicad has done
a very good job
at defining their ui all their logos
match
all their symbolism matches all the text
is the same
and it's got a very good graphic design
element to it
bricscad on the other hand when i first
opened it up and had a good play with it
personally i didn't find the graphics
and the logos and the symbols
all to be uniform it was like they were
jumping between cartoon images and logos
to 2d lines to kind of autocad style
logos and revit style logos so
it seemed to be a bit of a mix match
between all of the different
symbols and logos but overall it did
have
still a very clean very uniform look
there was nothing off-putting about the
ui it was all minimalistic and black
which personally i prefer
so when you first open it up you are
greeted with a very nice ui
one major difference here when you open
up archicad versus when you open up
bricscad
archicad is a dedicated standalone
program it's just
archicad bricscad on the other hand has
multiple different versions that you can
open up for example
it has the shape option which is
completely free
it has the mechanical the drafting and
the bim
so there's a number of different
functionalities and features that you
can go into
once you start brix cad if you're
looking at just doing some massing you
go into shape
if you're looking at doing more
architectural work or more engineering
work you'd go into bim
and you'd use the program as it needed
for that stage
archicad for the other hand is all built
into one
so as you progress through the stages
you stay on the same software neither of
this is really a pro and a con
they both have the capabilities of doing
the exact same thing
just in a different manner how you
prefer to do your stages
if you're somebody who likes to go from
sketchup
do the massing and blocking and stacking
and then go into something like revit
and really detail it then brix cad might
actually be the perfect feature for you
it has that ability to give you the
blocking and stacking
and then the bim capabilities whereas
archicad you kind of dive straight into
the
bim management and bim software straight
away when it comes to construction
documentation
it becomes imperative that all of your
information is very clear and very
detailed
in my opinion when i've used arcad and
when i use bricscad to document a
project
there were two very similar but very
different programs
archicad for example i have a lot of
experience in so i can do things quickly
i'll take that out of the equation
archicad has the ability
to really fine tune everything in 3d
align everything and it is a
self-sufficient
3d bim modeling program when i started
modeling on bricscad on the other hand
it kind of reminded me a lot more of the
autodesk bim management software
so it's kind of similar to revit but
crossed with autocad at the same time
you have the ability to type in commands
but you have the ability
to draw in 3d so i think for anybody
that
is coming from an autodesk background in
to the bim management world this is
definitely a viable option that you
should be considering
the same way you can dimension tag walls
add doors
animate your windows etc in archicad you
can do the same thing in bricscad
it is a very different process and again
i'm not as familiar with it
so it took me a little bit longer to
figure out how to actually
do all these bits and pieces but once i
got the hang of it
it was very similar and very easy to use
i think personally speaking
again trying to take out the fact that i
know
archicad a lot better i still do
personally believe that documentation is
quicker on archicad than it would be on
bricscad
but potentially if you had a lot more
experience in bricscad it might be a
little bit quicker you might know
all the tips and tricks but for me it's
still something
very different between documenting on
archicad and documenting on bricscad
so what are the pros of both softwares
so let's start with the pros of both
programs
first of all archicad archicad has been
a long time favorite for students and
universities
a lot of firms out there use archicad
and it is a desirable thing
to have on your resume it has a very
clean ui multiple plugins
and very very user friendly it is
incredibly stable with ifc files which
is the future of bim management
and it is able to communicate with
almost any single software out there
overall archicad has a very strong base
and is a good consideration for your
first
and also your last software to learn
brix cad on the other hand is kind of
what revit was like
10 years ago revit has now stopped
innovating
they're no longer focusing on
architecture and they're solely focusing
on engineering
like they've unfortunately stated
bricscad is again
focusing on the architecture they're
putting the time and effort and energy
into updating all these features year
after year after year
at the moment they're on version 20
they've implemented so many features
that they've caught up and surpassed
most of the basic features in archicad
and revit they've gone ahead and even
added ai
automation in to their documentation
phases
so right now in archicad you definitely
can't go ahead and rely
on archicad to do any ai it doesn't even
have that capability
brix cad on the other hand has the ai
capability
to really try and push forward and
generate
models and documentation better and
quicker so from a pro point of view i
think bricscad
is really innovating and pushing and
nipping at the heels of archicad and
rivet
to really make sure they grow as
companies but brix cad is able to
surpass them
i wouldn't be surprised if in five years
time it became very normal
that it was either revit or bricscad or
archicad in bricscad and it was no
longer just
archicad and revit that most people
discussed and deliberated
between which software they should learn
if you're ahead of the curve and want to
start exploring new programs
it's definitely a good time to go and
learn bricscad
because they have a 30-day free trial
that's how i got
my software that's how i explored the
software so if you want to sign up for
30 days for
completely free no sponsorship from me
no nothing whatsoever
jump on their website download it for
free have a good play
see if it's worth you learning and
investing your hard earned money into
what about the cons well archicad has a
lot of them believe it or not
archicad requires a lot of plugins to do
the job well
at the moment we use cad image keynotes
and also roof coverings and we use 4d
libraries
and a whole bunch of other things to be
able to produce the documentation and
the quality of work that we do at the
moment at my office
unfortunately this means that there is
the base price of five and a half
thousand dollars plus the 700
yearly maintenance fee for archicad but
then you also have all the plugins that
go with it
so all of a sudden archicad has gone
from 700
a year in maintenance to like 1200 as a
year of maintenance
it becomes very expensive very very
quickly
one of the cons i think personally for
me for brix cad is the fact that here in
australia at least
not many firms are using brick cad so it
isn't a desirable
skill to have i know that in the us the
uk
and around the rest of the world
bricscad is breaking through
and they're already with some major
firms that means if you want to work for
one of these
top firms you're probably going to need
to know bricscad
in addition to that i think bricscad's
ui system is very different from
archicad and very similar to revit
so if you're an archicad user moving to
bricscad it's going to take you a little
bit of time to learn
if you're an autodesk user moving to
bricscad
you're going to pick that up so quickly
it's going to be like second nature to
you
so that's a con only for the people
transitioning from archicad to bricks
garden so what's my overall verdict well
personally in australia i don't see that
bricscad
has pushed into the market so much that
it demands every university student to
learn
if you're in the us uk or around the
world then
you have a lot more opportunities to
find a firm that will be using bricscad
on the other hand if you are an
australian firm
or any firm around the world looking for
a new program
to be able to run your system and your
whole office on
i think brxcad is definitely a viable
option
especially considering the price the
biggest
downfall for most firms is having to
flip five thousand ten thousand dollars
a year on
licensing for just software that
their staff have to use that's five ten
thousand
per staff member if you had ten staff
members that's a hundred thousand
australian dollars
every year that you have to flip the
bill for before you make a single dollar
versus bricscad for example it would
only cost you
twenty thousand dollars for ten staff
members for the first set up year
it gets cheaper and cheaper along the
way so
from a financial point of view it
definitely makes sense
to pick the more viable option anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button down below it helps this video
get shown to more people
and helps this channel grow if you
enjoyed it and want to see more of my
content make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
and as always i'll see you next monday